dieses Sandwich kostet nur 1 € und ist
das perfekte Grill cheese Sandwich glaub
mir wenn ich sag dass ihr das nachmachen
müsst und eigentlich ist es verrückt
dass 1 € kostet weil das sind alle
Zutaten die wir brauchen wir haben zwei
Scheiben Toast 27 Cent ein bisschen
Butter 10 Cent sandwichkäse 17 Cent und
eine Scheibe biogauder 25 Cent das ganze
wird ein gr cheese Sandwich zunächst
einmal bestreichen wir unsere Brote mit
Butter was ich ganz gerne mache ist das
Sandwich in der Pfanne zu belegen also
mit der Butterseite nach unten die
Pfanne darf ein bisschen vorgeheizt sein
aber nicht zu heiß dann folgt unser
Gauder für den Geschmack und unser
sandwichkäse für den Schmelz Deckel
drauf und ein wenig Geduld wealten
lassen man darf wirklich nicht mit zu
hoher Hitze arbeiten wenn man möchte
dass der Käse schön durchgeschmolzen ist
wenn es die perfekte Farbe erreicht hat
flippen wir das Ganze und so darf es und
soll es aussehen goldbraun und
gleichmäßig schön knusprig und jetzt
beschweren wir das ganze s dass der Käse
noch besser zusammenschmilzt und einfach
eine Masse entsteht und fertig ist unser
Grill cheese Sandwich jetzt noch Ketchup
und Mayo dazu dann sind wir bei 1 € und
können unser Sandwich genießen